Samuel leaves here and one of the things
that you need to be a successful
property investor in fact to be
successful just about in anything in
life is you need a whole lot of
confidence you need bags and bags of
confidence and one of the things I see
holding people back is not their lack of
competence but their lack of confidence
if that's you this video is for you so
stay tuned I think one of the reasons
people are afraid to be confident is
because they're afraid to appear
arrogant or they don't want to step out
in faith and say this is what I'm doing
and then it go wrong and then look like
an idiot with egg on their face but the
thing is unless you speak out it's not
going to happen anyway you've got to
write down the vision make it plain so
that all can see some people say oh I'll
believe it when I see it but you've got
to you've got it you've got to believe
it first and then you see it and to do
that you got to have faith you could
have loads of confidence so the grapple
the fine line in my opinion between
arrogance and confidence because they're
not all that arrogant they don't want to
look cocky is arrogance says that you're
amazing and everyone else is rubbish and
you're the best whereas whereas
confidence says no one's better than me
but I'm not better than anyone and I'm
awesome you're awesome let's do this I
think that's confidence so that's the
first thing
Will Smith says that the best things in
life are always on the other side of
fear so if you're afraid about being
successful you're afraid about stepping
that you're afraid about picking up the
phone you're afraid about just being
confident and going for it just remember
that if you're afraid that's a good
thing because one if you're not growing
you're dying and the only way to grow is
to step out your comfort zone but to
when you push past that fear there's
always something glorious on the other
side that's the reason that I bungee
jumps often i bungee jump just because I
find it terrifying
it's petrifying and as soon as you jump
suddenly the glory comes so it's the
same in anything so if you're afraid
you're afraid to pick up the phone
you're afraid to put in an offer you're
afraid to ask ask to borrow money you're
afraid to sign the papers for the
contracts for the property do it just do
it as long as you're competent because
there's nothing more dangerous than a
motivate idiot so remember number one is
no one's better than you and you're not
better than anyone but number two is the
best things in life are always on the
other side of fritter so don't be afraid
be confident and lastly once you've done
that you've got a you've got to do this
that I do before I make any decision I
always say what's the best case scenario
and then what's the worst case scenario
and then what's likely to happen what's
likely to be the outcome and then once
you've done that you can then make a
decision so best case let's say the best
case is you make a thousand pounds worst
case is you go bankrupt and have a
divorce then just I wouldn't even bother
looking at the likely case because the
best case is like okay fine
worst case is terrible so you go look at
the best case worst case worst case is
can I live with that is that going to
financially bankrupt me is that going to
[ __ ] me what's the best case and then
the likely case and then you can just
use your gut your intuition and your
common sense looking at these three
things and then five four three two want
it once you've got the decisions in
front of you you can just say right wait
is it a good decision and come up with a
yes or a No I hate maybes maybe some
really bad I always say advise yourself
as if you're advising someone else
because you always give yourself bad
advice but you give other people good
advice so best case worst case likely
case what would you advise someone else
to do what did you gut say great when
you've got all the facts on the table by
the way usually that takes me like 20
seconds then it's just 5 4 3 2 1
you do it you make a decision Richard
Branson says if someone offers you an
opportunity if a good deal comes along
say yes then figure out later so
hopefully that's helped step out be
confident no one's better than you you
are awesome
don't be a motivate idiot always work
out the risk and the worst case scenario
wait up and then just do it god bless
you see you next time thank you so much
for watching if you benefited on that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time